today we will attempt in a group to um
build um a hopefully better NLP model
than what's currently available you out
of the box if you just prompt a large
language model and we've already done
some experiments it's looking pretty
good so um you know we'll all be working
together on this and to give you a
little intro who we are what we're doing
um we're probably yeah most known for
Spacey which is an open source library
for natural language processing in
Python it's um yeah um been very popular
um and it really focuses on um applied
real world use cases building pipelines
combining different techniques from you
know the latest machine learning um
models to you know business logic um and
it was really designed from the ground
up to be used in real projects and in
production um and it's also very
fast and uh we also um published Prodigy
which is an anotation tool that
integrates with spacy and helps you
create training data um both you know in
efficient ways and UI and also in smart
ways by automating things and Prodigy is
very widely used by lots of different
companies um and users in all kinds of
Industries and um it covers a wide range
of tasks and will'll also be using
prodigy and our latest upcoming product
Prodigy teams um which is kind of brings
the whole thing into the cloud and is a
collaborative data development platform
to create some data for the model that
we're going to train uh today to see how
good we can get and um you know how how
we can uh surpass uh what's currently
available um in the world of large
language
models and so one really important
important distinction I want to start
with for this Workshop is the the
distinction between generative and uh
predictive models and capabilities I
feel like if you follow if you scroll
through your LinkedIn feed or follow the
news on um everything happening in the
space this is often kind of um you know
talked about as one thing and sort of um
or uh um yeah presented as um the same
thing when actually these capabilities
are quite different so usually when
people talk about stuff like chat GPT um
these models are really good at these
generative tasks so we have stuff like
summarization reasoning problem solving
paraphrasing style transfer question
answering and these are all tasks where
a text comes in and a text um or
something else comes comes out and is
generated but then there's this whole
other area of predictive tasks where the
output is really more machine readable
and the model is more of a part of a
larger system so that's stuff like
information extt ction um text
classification entity recognition
relation extraction cor reference
resolution um semantic passing discourse
structure grammar so all of these things
that maybe people call Classic n tasks
but they are still extremely important
because there are many use cases where
you want to populate a database you want
to create structured data and while a
lot of the large models that are coming
out can really help with that they
actually
surprisingly um yeah some surprisingly
bad at these things which you wouldn't
believe um you know if you just
scrolling through your LinkedIn feed and
get the message of like oh NLP is
practically solved but you know if your
goal is to create um structured
information out at the end of it with a
generative model um there's a lot of
room for improvement so that's also what
we're looking at to see hey how can we
get past that um and how can we maybe
use what's clearly there and all the
great capabilities um that we also you
know use in our everyday life like
um you know using chat GPT to help with
writing code and answering questions
around that there's like a lot of
clearly there's like so much in there
but how can we use that and kind of take
it to the next level that's really what
we want to focus on in this workshop and
um to give you some examples these are
some experiments we ran um before where
we basically looked at how does um a
model trained on data like for a
specific um task compared to
um a zero few short um results you get
out of the box with different large
language models and um basically here
the um Dash lines those are um you know
the Baseline um with no training
examples and then you see um the results
of models framed on different portions
of the data so 1% 5% 10% and so on and
what we can see here is that for
especially the sentiment data set news
data set we get like pretty good zero
shot results out of the box and that's
something to work with but um for harder
use cases even with like very small
amounts of data like 1% 5% we can
definitely beat those scores and um
build a model that's even better for
that one specific task and especially
once it get the task gets a bit harder
like um banking data with 77 categories
um which is domain specific a lot of
labels and here even with 5% of the data
we get like you know a huge Improvement
um and if we train from the whole data
set that's like a very very um you know
uh significant
difference and recently we also ran some
experiments with for identity
recognition so extracting um named
Concepts from text um which was very
difficult because like a lot of these um
models keep timing out it's very it's
very hard actually to run these structed
experiments and especially the more you
include in the prompt the more more
hopeless it gets but um basically what
we've seen here is that even with 20
training examples we on this data set we
can beat um the claw 2 model so this all
of this looked very promising to us we
like okay how can we how can we turn
this into a workflow that's actually
usable by people and how can we um you
know extract um the information that's
there and then build build better models
that are faster um really
um you know specializing on this one
particular task and how do we find these
inflection points basically where um we
can see okay that's how much data we
need to uh train a model that's that
outperforms um the baseline or the best
possible Baseline so that's also what we
try and look at uh today um how can we
get there can we get there as a group
and also what workflows are there that
let you um um use these workflows in
your day-to-day n
life and so what we try to what we're
going to try and do today is this we'll
use um data uh annotated by a large
language model um and um you know using
a prompt uh that we've tuned and
identified as like you know at least the
best possible one we're going to use it
use the predictions to help us create
data that's correct correct all the
mistakes and then use that data to train
a supervised bird size model um that's
smaller more efficient that you know you
can run on your even on your um you know
modern laptop these days almost or on a
single machine and then um during
inference we'll have this Spacey model
that hopefully you know should perform
as good or maybe even better yeah we'll
we'll we'll create
our model um so we're going to use
instead of um you know using the large
language model or API at run time we're
going to use it at development time to
get the best possible information out of
it and then turn that into like a
distilled down version um that's better
and more efficient so that's that's what
we're going to attempt interactively
today also if you haven't signed up yet
there's this bitly URL on the Whiteboard
here um just put in your Det details and
then we'll invite you uh to the platform
we're going to use to collaborate on the
data for our model and now I hand over
to
Ryan well good morning everyone um we're
very excited as always workshops
especially demoing new software is
always challenging but so far before we
get into the workshop just a little bit
about myself so my name is Ryan weson
I'm a machine learning engineer at
explosion and also the Prodigy customer
lead so I've been working with explosion
for about a year and a half now and I'm
not just a use well not just work for
explosion but I've been using Spacey and
especially Prodigy um in previous roles
so I previously managed an NLP team at
Bank of America so Prodigy itself I
think as Enis had kind of said is a
python library for fast efficient data
annotation so today with the workshop
what we actually want to do now is start
to use our um as software as a Service
uh platform called Prodigy
teams um just as one more hash because I
I know that there's still a few more
people but getting into what the actual
task that we're going to be doing is as
enus was saying name entity recognition
but we want to actually now start to
take it one step further by allowing the
large language model to pre- annotate
the Neer model so I'm just curious here
who here has ever labeled any data for
an NLP
model got 1 2 3 4 five six I I like the
couple of handset it's like well I kind
of did in Excel does that count labeling
data is a challenging problem especially
for Applied in op it's very easy to find
you know Wonderful notebooks with u data
sets that have already been labeled but
for a lot of practitioners actually
applying it to specific problems
requires you some sometimes of rolling
up your sleeves and labeling data so
especially for those of you guys that
are familiar with labeling data you
realize that you know it's it's a
challenge in a lot of ways you know
determining for let's say a task like
name entity recognition defining what is
an organization it might seem intuitive
to begin with but then when you actually
look through trying to Define what that
entity type is can be a little
challenging so as the first example that
we want to kind of walk in pretty slowly
before before we have our major task
which we'll let you guys label for 15
minutes we want to First do what we're
calling a QA or kind of pilot anotation
so this is where um what we'll be doing
is looking at redded data so we'll be
specifically looking at the subreddit of
cooking and we wanted to try to find a
task that was fairly intuitive because
again sometimes some NLP tasks can be
very specific maybe you're looking at
medical terminology so you need an
incredible background in that specific
field and this was also something too as
Enis had kind of showed with some of our
initial results and looking at large
language models kind of pre-annotation
so this is again zero shot where you
might only give them a prompt or a few
shop where you give them a prompt in a
few examples it really varies as far as
how well they can actually perform
depending on the task itself so we
decided read cooking data one because it
was something fairly easy to define a
prompt and we could prompt engineer that
and we have a few examples of the
prompts that we use but more
specifically we wanted something kind of
clearcut in the definition for you guys
as well too so with the subreddit for
cooking what we're going to be looking
for are entity types that are either a
dish an ingredient or equipment and
there's a lot of ways you know maybe
thinking about the practical purposes is
maybe I want to try to look at Reddit
data and I'm in the business is selling
cooking equipment and I want to now
start to Target what are the big trends
is it certain Mexican dishes that are
becoming more popular and what are the
equipment that people are using so this
is where again this idea of name entity
recognition this information extraction
task could be potentially very valuable
if we were able to Define and build our
own model and so we have these
definitions and as you kind of start to
go through you'll find well these
definitions make sense you know
everyone's kind of maybe have their own
recipe and try to create their own dish
and thinking about like ingredients well
when you think about that it's really as
what are the inputs to a dish itself you
can think of the dish as say the output
the final thing that you're actually
going to be uh consuming whereas then
the equipment might be the means that
you get to for that actual dish itself
so these are again some of the things to
think about when we go through our first
pilot kind of Q&A where we'll talk
through the first five
examples um but as I do this I do
suspect that we might have and we can
actually switch
over this is actually so just one heads
up is that anyone we've sent out inin so
if you see your email address here you
actually need to go to your email and
just acknowledge that you've been
invited to the system because until you
do that I can't send you the link for
The annotation
itself um so there's a few people here
and again this I I would actually say
for this first one if you don't want to
even actually annotate that's completely
fine as well because we'll talk through
these first five
examples um and then I also
suspect we've gotten a few yeah 36 and I
was at 30 so one
two
yeah yeah so what it is is that so like
for example I'm adding these six people
so if you see your email here you just
need to go to that email address and
then acknowledge that you've been sent
this invite to go into the system
because once you're in the system then
I'll actually go to our task and assign
you to do the annotations for
those so again let me pause to make
certain everyone because there's about
like 20 people that they're all ready to
go I can start sending out the
annotations now but I don't want to
leave anyone behind but I know it's lots
of things it's first thing in the
morning too it's raining
you um let me see if that is that number
going down so we still have 12 more
people um so again just in the interest
of time um if you are you know again you
would have to just go to your email and
acknowledge um but while we're looking
at this too just to give you guys a
sneak preview of Prodigy teams or latest
product this is the user interface where
for a developer or admin would be able
to manage start create um stop and also
assign tasks for
annotation so in this example we've
actually already created two separate
tasks our Neer tasks and what we're
first going to be doing is this QA pilot
or what I'm now going to do is all
everyone so we have 28 people I'm now
going to add you as annotators and so
for that now you should have received an
email that says Ryan WL has invited you
to do a labeling task and a big old
button
hopefully everything oh we already are
starting to get so if you were to get
that email it would then hopefully lead
you
to
Boom are some people able
to yeah yeah yeah
yeah who can see the okay things are
working now one fun thing we have with
this and I think a few of you guys maybe
have used Prodigy before maybe other
annotation tools we actually added
something this call back to these five
examples that we want to label first
because what we want this as is a Q&A
that is if you don't get the correct
annotation so we as a team actually went
through these five documents and
annotated them you'll actually get a
popup box that says no your annotation
isn't
correct yeah so
yeah let's yeah you can do soup let
pause or actually no that's Curry is in
that context a dish yeah so I I I now
and now yeah so well no no so there's
one actually if you just switched Curry
to a
dish so and then pause one
second yeah so one thing that's already
challenging what's the difference
between an ingredient and a dish you
know sometimes again maybe a stew might
be thought of as an ingredient in some
ways but then sometimes it also might be
kind of that actual last output that
dish that you're serving so one of the
first things as you go through this task
is really thinking about the context
itself how is it actually being used in
that sentence as a Dish versus an
ingredient now looking at this is this a
correct annotation or is there anything
that we could improve upon
this cauliflower what what is it is it
just cauliflower
or cauliflower
leaves so one thing to think about this
in information extraction we are taking
unstructured text and we want to try to
carve out what are the specific things
we want to extract out and if you think
about this you know if we were to say
just cauliflower that might mean
something completely different than
cauliflower leaves so we we need to be
extremely mindful of the actual bounds
of the entity types and for those of you
guys that are deeply aware of kind of
NLP tasks especially name entity
recognition the boundaries is incredibly
important to be specific on now whereas
for some especially any Spacey users who
have maybe used our span C component
that's one that has a little bit more
flexibility in allowing you overlapping
um entity bounds but in this example we
need to be very thoughtful about the
boundaries themselves because that's the
way in which for the model to be trained
it's really looking at very defined
boundaries so for this yep you can click
this now this second one oh you already
jumped to it oh sorry yeah same yeah so
what's the issue with this so our large
language model and few shot said this is
an
equipment yeah the m is in there so in
this we're actually just really looking
at so we would then go to equipment
Pro 50 and that's what we're looking for
so oh yeah so to to en's point too and
this is actually something that
especially if you haven't done a lot of
data annotation before one thing that
Prodigy does is using the tokenizer
allows you to do these snap
boundaries one thing just in my
experience and I remember this five six
years ago before doing NLP I thought
tokenizers was a very trivial thing but
when you're actually annotating
especially spans of text what tokenizer
you use at the time of annotation is
extremely important because you need to
have a consistent tokenizer that you're
actually using during training as well
too so if you don't have a tokenizer
that allows you to snap there's always
the possibility of a human error that I
accidentally go a little bit too far too
back or from a specific actual text
itself so that's again just some of the
things that's built into prodigy so
here's another
example so we have the large language
model had predicted these ingredients is
this
correct anyone want
to good yeah i' just say garlic Min
garlic oh you would say garlic versus
you don't think minc garlic is that's
part of the process that's part of the
process oh that's an interesting thing
so we actually talked about this and we
were actually thinking that like when
you actually putting in the ingredients
we thought M garlic is what you need
because if you were to just half of that
just regular garlic so that's actually
but this is where it's a great point on
that that like thinking through we
actually were thinking that it would be
minced garlic um but I think you bring
up a fair point
Yeahs oh the cups the measurements yeah
that's this is really the one why we
wanted to kind of show this example we
have decided and this goes back to our
definitions that measurements are not a
part of the entity now again some would
argue that to get the recipe you might
actually want that and this is where
what you might want to do on a second
round is now having a fourth entity Ty
called the measurement but what we just
we decided as annotation guidelines and
this is where it's just so critical
before you start annotating you have a
clear knowledge and thinking about what
are you trying to annotate and there's
not a perfect definition so for example
you know if we were to be very clear
that like we think garlic should only be
there not minced on that we just need to
Define what that is but in this case we
made the decision and for your labeling
task that measurements won't be a part
of this entity time it's an interesting
one because like yeah in English you
have like the cup that's like in this
case a measure like a unit but also an
actual cup so you can like you know
there might be cases where like he I
don't know stir an egg in a cup where
the cup would be an equipment and then
the model could get confused because in
other languages you your measurements
are a bit more yeah and one of the nice
things and especially when we get in
about five minutes once you guys start
labeling for 15 minutes you will find so
many counter examples of things you
never even thought was there and this is
the beauty and this is also why I I also
um be clear or think about this from my
experience one of the reasons why like I
loved Prodigy as an NLP practitioner
because there's a lot of times that a
data scientist think annotation isn't my
role that's someone else's that's the
annotators just give me the data I just
have to hyper tune my parameters and
that's it and call it a day and instead
with prodigy or a lot of other
annotation tools for data scientists to
get their hands dirty especially early
on in projects and trying to Define what
are these entity types and being very
clear about it is one of the leading uh
ways in which projects can be successful
as opposed to when they fail
because you're not even defining what
are you trying to label so um in this
this is actually one that we as a group
now again you know we could debate and
maybe there's whole other things but we
actually decided this that one was
correct um two other ones so in this one
is this
correct why not it'sh it's a dish how
did you infer
that oh there's no other food yeah it's
talking about the sides that are there
but this is another one that and this is
where you know my background is more in
Psychology like human language
understanding how quickly someone can
read that and immediately infer that
versus and all not to U get too hard on
large language models when you guys
start annotating you will be very
impressed with sometimes their ability
but there's other times that they still
struggle on this short context and so
this is again the whole idea is we build
from the large language models to kind
of get us a good first start because
it's much easier to correct than if
there was nothing on there um but it's
as well something that you know um
someone can try to figure out so this is
the last one before we jump
in what's the thoughts on
this TV show that's actually a TV
show so it's again one of these that you
know thinking about the context but one
other reason reason that we want to show
you this example and some of this is
also the design of Prodigy is so Prodigy
is designed for one document at a time
allowing annotators to make quick
efficient decisions we sometimes have
Prodigy users that want to put like all
types of data just like five pages of
documents and instead it's not really
built for that it's built for a very
quick decision and one thing that I just
want to note on this is that Prodigy has
this accept reject and ignore buttons so
in this
context even though I don't have any
entity types I would still be accepting
this because it's an example where there
aren't any that the model needs to learn
from so when you guys go through your
actual task itself if you go come to any
that there aren't entities in there
that's completely fine and that's still
something that you would click this
button or you can actually even use the
keyboard a for a fast shortcut on this
the reject button that's there that's
usually only times where you want to
throw out an example maybe you have a
poor tokenization or something like that
for probably the vast majority you'll
guys during your task will just
highlight the spans and then move on to
the next one and then the last just for
context two before we jump in that third
button the skip um that's one that just
again it's almost like you'll get back
to later I also want to say with the
task that you guys are going through
with Reddit data we chose specifically
the cooking subreddit hoping that there
might not be explicit language but oh
social media finds a way so we again try
to curate and try to remove but there
are some um explicit language so when
you are labeling if you're one of the
lucky ones that get one of those
documents you're more than welcome to
just skip it and not have to read it um
yeah so like skip in general I think is
is a good strategy like don't waste like
minutes on a single example like I also
did a bunch of annotation before the
workshop and there is some stuff where
you're like yes you can sit down and
debate like on a philosophical level
what's a dish and Google some stuff but
like it's kind of not worth it the value
of the individual example isn't that
high like it's much better to stay in
that Groove and move on rather than um
really getting too hung up on one
example that might not make a difference
and yeah also once we're um getting to
it and like you get to annotate
definitely remember to like if you see
some cool examples some interesting ones
some funny ones there's definitely like
so much in there take a screenshot we
can also discuss some of those later and
they also make really good content for
social media um to sh like some some of
them are really um really good and if
you yeah definitely don't forget to take
screenshots of what you come across oh
yeah and so before okay um before we
actually get into the task one last
thing that is just good to have a good
mental model about an annotation process
is that we kind of have this feedback
loop were at this first step and you can
think of this is even this QA pilot we
first want to annotate it the second and
very very critical is this evaluate now
again if we wanted to go through this as
say a lot of companies or a lot of
initial projects start this could be
several hours to several days this is
why we wanted to have go through these
five examples to talk through as a group
you know talk through you know whether
we agree or disagree with what our
definitions are do we what we're
actually labeling do we find um that we
might need more data or other
circumstances again in this given this
Workshop we've really kind of
oversimplified this but then the third
part is then now that we've had any of
those discussions usually if you were
again to put this as a model that our
project moving forward you then might
want to update your annotation
guidelines so maybe those five examples
maybe it's a document that you put those
five examples along with the definitions
so any new annotators can kind of learn
from those examples um we do have and we
don't have a link to this but um about a
year ago I wrote a wonderful blog on uh
the guardian the newspaper that used our
tool Prodigy and they had a wonderful
annotation guidelines on finding quote
extraction and the reason we wrote that
blog is that I think for a lot of NLP
practitioners they might not have even
seen what good annotation guidelines
look like and so and it's again for some
that like you know um being able to look
through that kind of set of definitions
and iterating on that was something that
the guardian team had actually worked on
pretty effectively for this so this is
again this whole idea that we can't
fully go through this because this might
be you know several hours if not several
days but it's again what we want to try
to zoom into in this workshop for
now well yeah we can we can go through
this a bit quickly I will also share the
slides after but um basically what we've
done is we've uh configured Spacey via
its uh Spacey llm package um to use um
an llm um
gp35 um in this case to uh pre-label
examples on the right side you see uh
The Prompt template we also use
different prompt templates um for
comparison and um yeah so that's kind of
where we're at out of the box so we
started labeled some evaluation examples
because we need to you know be able to
compare um what we're doing and how
different models are performing and
here's kind of this is the Baseline
that's what we are trying to work
against so you can see we've tried a
zero short approach so just prompt take
whatever we get back we've tried um The
Chain of Thought prompting which we've
also implemented in Spacey and we've
tried a f shot approach so these are the
results results and what we're trying to
find out is where can we get compared to
this with a task specific model um that
we trained that really only does this
one task yeah but actually I think we
are now we actually getting closer to
like a sizable data set that's also
similar to um the sets we've done
experiments with also as you can see
like this wasn't like a very focused
annotation session people were chatting
it was more fun um but still we created
quite a lot of data so you couldn't you
know easily imagine that if you actually
sat down with a team of people and did
this focused as part of a job you could
very very quickly create quite a lot of
data um that way and have enough to
train a model so yeah Ryan you just want
to quickly show like how what the next
steps yeah yeah yeah so just again going
back to the Prodigy teams user interface
so this is again the thought process of
this product is you would have an
administrator or developer who's the one
one that's administering this task and
so all of you guys were annotators which
was a separate role that is you only get
the link to your specific annotations
and the tasks that are there but this
gives a little bit of a high level
summary about you know what's currently
going on and you see this actually
refreshing with some of these examples
let's see if I can find my mouse oh
there it
is um and so again we can actually look
through some of these what's really nice
as well too is you can actually look at
the the actual Json structure for this
um there's lots of nitty-gritty details
that actually is being done underneath
the hood with the tokenization that's
there um but some of the other key
things to just look at is you know look
at what we've accomplished in 30 minutes
we have
734 annotations which is a lot um about
7 hours worth of work you guys have done
you guys need to take a break you guys
have been doing amazing look at this
already in the morning in 7 hours worth
of annotation
anybody has UNS oh yeah before you close
your browser make sure to hit
save last yeah and as you guys are kind
of finishing up and so if I were
to just so you see so there's this
little button because the way in which
Prodigy sends out annotations is in
batches and so until you actually get
through that usually that 10 batch it's
actually saved locally in your browser
but it's not until that point that
either you get through those 10 that
then it retrieves 10 more of those or
you click that save button so it's only
the last 10 or so that are there um oh
actually no I take that back you guys
now that you saved it's actually about
1,200 annotations so thank you for that
save 10 hours worth of work amazing job
you guys um so again this provides some
of the information uh for let's say the
administrator or the developer to kind
of look through we can can also actually
see the individual sessions so you know
I did my contribution of learning
annotation work really hard um but thank
you to some of you guys 263 3258 well
done um there's also a lot of other
features that and this is again just a
preview where you can actually look at
the logs this is extremely helpful to
debug and any issues that are come about
um but what we also have so in Prodigy
teams there's kind of two things that
you can do the first is a task itself so
this is like where we use the Neer what
we call a recipe which just think about
that as kind of the um structure of what
the task is so maybe defining what the
label is the data set that's there um
this is where and just as kind of a
quick preview you know if we wanted to
right now hey we've done 10 hours worth
of work let's let's do some co-reference
resolution while we're at it we won't of
course um but this is the normal kind of
structure as what the product would then
allow you maybe image
annotation uh but the second thing we
want to show you too is the actions part
of Prodigy teams which is really nice
because what you might also have is some
sort of computation that you want to do
on your data set so usually the most
obvious one is say training so you could
actually go through we decided to just
avoid the complication of that um but in
theory we have it kind of preset with a
Spacey pipeline but again there's
nothing holding you back from
potentially running a high torch
pipeline or any other framework but in
advance of this we actually and my
colleague Kabir created this wonderful
recipe that just does some nice overall
statistics on our big data set that we
had and as I'm kind of rerunning this
so so yes so this is some very basic
information of the fruits of our labor
so we went through 1,200 examples uh
three 333 were examples without entities
so thank you guys for doing that that
was back to the point that you still
accepted when there was a document that
didn't have any entities on there um so
maybe about a fourth in total
3,700 actual spans or entities that you
guys labeled we can actually look at the
size of this so a vast majority were
ingredients uh dishes and Equipment
which this is pretty similar to what
we've seen before when we are team in
did some internal testing for this
what's also really nice too that we kind
of have and again the whole idea of this
is that with this action you can write a
python script to do whatever you want in
this example what we just wanted to do
is to show the top 10 most covered
entities so butter as an ingredient very
popular makes sense um pan an equipment
um we also have other oven for equipment
but again this is good we have some good
quality things you know we're not
assigning olive oil as an equipment so
this is a good kind of uh test for this
what's also kind of interesting too is
these 10 least covered entities where we
might try to find some inconsistency
sometimes now we do have some case
sensitivity so also Buco um in both
contexts were assigned a dish um at some
point we assigned hypertension and
ingredient which is so so the the one
key thing I would say on this so two
things is remember that when we have
this data pre-annotated from large
language models I hope one takeaway from
this is how powerful large language
models can be there were some context
like I remember annotating where there
might be a full paragraph of all these
ingredients and large language models
with f shot can detect a ton of them
immediately meaning you as an annotator
don't have to exhaust your very precious
cognitive load annotating every single
single one but every once in a while the
model is not perfect this is again the
value of you as a person and so my
suspicion and I could be completely
wrong was this was one where the large
language model had assigned hypertension
and someone just had kind of moved
forward with it or alternatively was
confused on this but again one
annotation like this in the grand scheme
of things is not the end of the world
and it's actually something we would
assume in a lot of annotation workflows
as
well um so going through we actually had
and this was a really kind of other cool
analysis that Kabir had put into this is
also comparing some of the entities
where we've assigned them different
labels at different times so we can
actually see this and this actually
makes a lot of sense as we were talking
about it that there are some entities
that it really again depends on the
context the like that example that we
showed with turkey and if I say I'm
going to put turkey into my sandwich
that turkey is actually an ingredient to
my my sandwich which is my dish but if I
say I can't wait for Thanksgiving and
our amazing turkey dinner you know in
that context is more as the turkey is
that actual dish itself so this was
again a nice little comparison where we
were just trying to again look at some
very basic statistics and comparison of
okay how did some of these different
entity types compare when they were used
as two different
entities um I think there's a couple
other wow we have a lot oh and there was
actually a few of these where we might
find you know issue we would expect this
a lot and as we saw with um Dish versus
ingredient but we did have a few you
know are some examples that you know we
might have found the contrary and so
again we're all human beings we make
mistakes we can't expect our data to be
100% perfect and usually in this process
what we would actually want to do is
multiple rounds of the data and we'll
get into this a little bit but you might
want to have certain people annotate the
same examples and have some judicator or
interannotator agreements as well too
where you go through multiple stages to
try to avoid some of these issues in the
data itself but again this is where we
wanted to show you guys that not just
the platform has some of the very basic
statistics how many annotations but
there's also creative ways of using
these actions to try to look at specific
um annotation stats to kind of help
someone that's administering this task
as they have many annotators real time
yeah of course you've been wondering how
did we do with our annotations well of
course we're not going to live train a
bird sized model because that's going to
take too long and we yeah also can't
rely on the internet connection but what
we did do is we actually already
prepared like you know as they doing
these cooking shows where they kind of
you know bring out this slow cooked beef
they already prepared so we did run our
own experiments we annotated um how many
examples did we have in total it was
actually very similar yeah it was
actually I think it was actually fewer
than we all did as the group so with
more examples um you know we can expect
the accuracy to even go go up a bit so
um yeah that's what we did and so as you
can see here we actually managed to
train a model on this data that is kind
of on par with the F shot approach it
does run um a lot faster at 200,000
words a second um it's very small um you
can you know have it have it run it
yourself
um and we also had to do did do a bit of
hyperparameter tuning I don't know Matt
if you want to comment on some of that
but um basically to make sure um that's
something we don't have in a in a
product yet but that you can you know we
could we were able to do locally uh to
make sure we get the best possible
results out of the data so even though
you know you look you might be looking
at this you're like oh it's kind of you
know it's kind of the same why what
would I want to do all of that um it's
still this model is how how one gab
maybe less right no yeah it's like less
than less than a gigabyte um you have it
as a little package you can run it
yourself you can run it on your laptop
um it's entirely private it really only
does the one thing that we wanted to do
um you can update it with more examples
you can add more um you know some rules
to it you can add um other components to
it and yeah 2,000 words per second um
that's really really good and really
fast and it's not even the fastest
you can get they also if if you train
like a CNN model depending on what
you're doing that will run out um how
how fast 20 10 yeah 10 to 20K words um a
second so you know there still there
kind of trade-offs to be made here um
but yeah that's um that's our results
and I would assume that using what we've
created today we would be able to train
a very similar model we're going to
share um after this we're going to share
the slides we're also going to share the
config so you can um you know repeat
something similar at home um and train
your own
models some quick takeaways from what we
did today um as we've seen um you know
generative models they can really
complement predictive um methodologies
and you know predictive models it's not
a direct replacement um you know even
though you know there might be people
who believe that or there might be you
know if if you follow a lot of the
reporting it's pretty one-sided um but
there's always a place for structured
data and you can use these models and
what's in there to better create that
for you but um just um you know letting
the model itself create that structure
data might not always be the best
approach like you can usually do better
than that and distill it down and build
something more specific because yeah one
great thing about structured data is
that you know a lot more about it you
know its structure and you can use that
to your advantage when building better
models and oh wait still
one um and yeah if yeah if you can do
that you'll be able to create much
better more accurate much much much
faster smaller and also fully private
models you don't have to send anything
through to through an API the model can
really run locally on your service which
is very important for a lot of use cases
and also quite cool like why not if you
can do it like you know always take it
to the next level and finally tooling as
we've seen is really important um the
human has like a lot of disadvantages um
like paying attention to stuff
performing a lot of steps in a row um
it's kind of in some ways it's great
Hardware in some other ways it's like
very inefficient and if we can use
tooling to get the most out of the human
where we really need it and um yeah all
of that to together hopefully we see as
like you know very promising path um
towards using everything that's new in
LLP um to really make a difference
[Applause]
thanks